grandes villes pour leur demander des
larges d'établir un plan d'action pour
protéger les personnes les plus
vulnérables
nous avons ensuite assisté à une phase
de ralentissement à partir de la
deuxième quinzaine de septembre où les
différentes mesures prises dans les
métropoles principalement touchées ont
permis de marquer une stabilisation
voire un léger reflux notamment à
bordeaux à nice à rennes et dans
d'autres villes
et enfin depuis une dizaine de jours une
accélération soudaine et spectaculaire
entre le 1er et le 12 octobre le nombre
de cas pour 100000 personnes en france
entière est passé de 107 à 190 avec des
niveaux particulièrement alarmant dans
certaines grandes villes 500 à lille et
saint-etienne 422 à grenoble près de 400
ans lyon et à paris
conséquente les capacités de réanimation
sont déjà très fortement sollicités en
particulier à paris où 46 % des lits de
réanimation sont occupés par des
patients qu'aux vide
le plus préoccupant est que le nombre de
cas augmente très rapidement chez les
personnes âgées ce qui va se traduire
nous le savons par l'arrivée très
prochaine à l'hôpital de nombreux
nouveaux patients cette évolution
s'observe je dédie chez nous comme chez
nos voisins vous voyez apparaître
deuxième vague épidémique dans toute
l'europe et vous observez que les
courbes sont convergentes cette
situation exigeait une réaction forte et
rapide car il n'était pas envisageable
de laisser nos hôpitaux faire face au
risque d'un nombre de maladies graves
qui dépasserait rapidement et
massivement nos capacités alors même
qu'il n'est plus possible
comme au cours de la première vague de
déprogrammer massivement d'autres pas
théologie grave nos professionnels de
santé admirable héroïque pendant la
première vague sont fatigués et prouver
je veux leur rendre hommage de façon
appuyer leurs dires
olivier veyrat on y reviendra que nous
mettons tout en oeuvre pour les soutenir
face à cette nouvelle vague de
l'épidémie mais je souhaite dans blick
clarifier un point
j'entends dire que la bonne réponse
aurait été de créer massivement des lits
supplémentaires en réanimation
plutôt que de prendre des mesures de
freinage de l'épidémie c'est doublement
faux aucun système hospitalier ne
seraient capables de faire face aux
conséquences d'une telle épidémie qui
pourrait conduire à des dizaines de
milliers d'hospitalisations grave si
nous ne faisions rien un amant pour
l'enrayer
et surtout surtout pour créer des lits
il ne suffit pas de s'équiper en
matériel et en locaux il faut aussi
former des médecins et des personnels
soignants spécialisés vous le savez bien
que c'est impossible en quelques mois
cela nécessite plusieurs années pour
soulager nos soignants et réduire le
nombre de malades toutes générations
confondues
la seule vraie stratégie possible c'est
donc le freinage de l'épidémie par le
respect strict des gestes barrières et
la réduction des contacts et des
interactions sociales
nous avons depuis plusieurs mois
adopter une stratégie de riposte graduée
et territorialisée préférant des mesures
ciblées ville par ville territoire par
territoire plutôt que d interdiction
généralisée
nous faisons le pari de la confiance
avec les élus locaux au premier rang
desquels les maires avec qui nous
dialoguons en permanence je veux le
redire sans eux sans le concours de
leurs services et ceux des autres
collectivités avec le rapport d assaut
ciation spécialisés qui viennent en aide
aux plus précaires qui s'occupe des plus
vulnérables
nous n'y arriverons pas toutes ces
mesures ont porté leurs fruits au
travail à l'école dans les transports
nous sommes parvenus au bon point
d'équilibré
je relève en particulier que la rentrée
scolaire s'est bien passé aujourd'hui
seuls 29 établissements sur 62 milles et
274 de classe sur cinq cent trente mille
sont fermés sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
j'en remercie tous les acteurs de la
communauté éducative mais mais une zone
de risques très élevés apparaît la plus
difficile à maîtriser les lieux où se
déroulent des rassemblements ou des
fêtes en famille ou entre amis là où on
est nombreux
ou on est rapproché pendant une certaine
durée
là où on ne porte pas le masque est là
où on perd le réflexe des gestes
barrières
c'est là que nous sommes le plus en
risque
c'est là que nous devons agir
prioritairement et collectivement c'est
pour cela que nous avons durci les
mesures sur les bars et les restaurants
d'abord à marseille et bordeaux
mi-septembre puis ces dernières semaines
dans 14 grandes villes et en guadeloupe
la dégradation de la situation sanitaire
nette et rapide montre que cela n'est
pas suffisant
en dépit des efforts de l'ensemble des
professionnels notamment les
restaurateurs c'est dans le but de
limiter ces interactions à risque que
nous avons décidé d'imposer un
couvre-feu sanitaire dans neuf
métropoles qui s'appliquera aux espaces
publics mais qui aura aussi pour
objectif de réduire les interactions
dans la sphère privée au cours des
prochaines semaines
cela passe d'abord par un mot d'ordre
général réduire le nombre de personnes
que nous rencontrons dans un cercle
conviviale chez soi
au restaurant dans les moments de
convivialité à l'extérieur c'est la
règle des six personnes que nous avons
appliqué au restaurant et que nous
appliquerons au rassemblement dans
l'espace public et que nous demandons à
chacune et chacun de respecter à son
domicile
cela passe par un dispositif nouveau
cette mesure de couvre feu sanitaire qui
entrera donc en vigueur vendredi
demain à minuit je vais vous en préciser
maintenant les modalités les territoires
d'abord soumis à ce couvre feu annoncé
par le chef de l'état hier soir son pari
et les sept autres départements d'île de
france
les métropoles de lyon lille toulouse
montpellier saint-etienne aix marseille
iii et grenoble
ce couvre-feu s'établira de 21h à 6h du
matin cela signifie qu'à 21h chacun
devra être chez soi et que sauf
exception tous les lieux commerces ou
services publics
recevant du public seront fermés ces
règles doivent bien entendu s'appliquer
avec bon sens comme pendant le
confinement certains déplacements
resteront autorisés pour des raisons de
santé pour aller à l'hôpital où aller
acheter des médicaments dans une
pharmacie de garde
par exemple pour des raisons
professionnelles si vous travaillez de
nuit ou que vos horaires de travail ne
vous permettent pas d'être chez vous à
21h
si vous avez un train ou un avion qui
arrive ou qui part après 21h il faudra
le cas échéant pouvoir montrer votre
billet si vous êtes contrôlés
si vous devez vous rendre auprès d'un
proche en situation de dépendance pour
sortir votre animal de compagnie près de
chez vous
comme pendant la période de confinement
il faudra pour sortir après 21h vous
munir d'une attestation prouvant que
vous répondez de l'une de ces exceptions
l'attestation et l'ensemble des
informations concernant la situation
sanitaire et des mesures relatives au
couvre-feu sont disponibles sur le site
du gouvernement qui j'espère va
s'afficher ou en appelant le numéro vert
0 800 100 30 00 voilà vous avez les
références du site qui s'affiche à
l'écran
de même certains établissements
échapperont naturellement à la fermeture
anticipée
il s'agit des établissements de santé et
médico-sociaux des structures d'accueil
des plus précaires les hôtels des
restaurants faisant la livraison à
domicile et des établissements publics
qui assure un service en soirée et la
nuit comme notamment les commissariats
dans les zones de couvre feu des règles
plus strictes continueront à s'appliquer
par ailleurs en journée par ailleurs par
exemple les débits de boisson restaurant
fermé les salles de sport également sauf
pour les enfants et les sportifs
professionnels qui acquit plique des
protocoles spécifiques les universités
et établissements du supérieur
appliqueront des règles d'occupation
limitant à 50 % la présence sur place
des étudiants et l'occupation des lieux
d'enseignement
je compte sur le sens des
responsabilités de chacune et chacun
d'entre vous pour appliquer ces règles
j'ai demandé à ce que notre dispositif
de contrôle soit adaptée à ces règles
nouvelles et ce dispositif va vous être
présenté par le ministre de l'intérieur
bonjour à vous monsieur le premier
ministre
effectivement le ministère de
l'intérieur sera donc chargé de
l'application comme pendant le
confinement de mesures qui seront plus
dures si j'ose dire pendant ce couvre
feu de 21 heures à 6 heures du matin
dans les zones évoquées par le premier
ministre je le répète l'ensemble des
régions la région ile de france c'est à
dire paris évidemment et trois
départements de petite couronne la seine
saint denis et hauts-de-seine
val-de-marne ainsi que les départements
de grande couronne l'essonne le
val-d'oise les yvelines et la
seine-et-marne et les villes métropoles
évoqué par le premier ministre lille
lyon aix marseille grenoble toulouse
montpellier saint-etienne et rouen pour
cela douze mille policiers et gendarmes
sont chaque nuit entre 21h et 6h
spécialement chargé de faire vérifier
effectivement les interdictions évoqué
par monsieur le premier ministre
plus tous les agents de police et de
gendarmerie qui travaille naturellement
à la sécurité des français qui pourront
par ailleurs avec les polices
municipales lorsque les mères
organiseront les services de nuit où les
organise déjà faire respecter les règles
évoqué par monsieur le premier ministre
qui rentrent donc en vigueur dans la
nuit de vendredi à samedi à partir de
minuit je voudrais évoquer également que
sur le site du ministère de l'intérieur
il y aura la possibilité de pouvoir
télécharger l'attestation nouvelle avec
les mesures qu'ils voient que monsieur
le premier ministre la possible de
télécharger également sur son téléphone
et de pouvoir le garder sur son
smartphone pour ceux qui l'ont
évidemment et qui se rechargera toutes
les heures puisque la des stations vaut
une heure lorsqu'il s'agit de
déplacement qui n'ont pas de lien avec
le travail
et bien sûr on pourra toujours continuer
à écrire sur un papier libre notamment
pour les personnes les plus âgées ou les
gens qui n'ont pas d'imprimante ou de
photocopieuses à disposition
immédiatement cette attestation de des
basques en dérogatoire pour
l'attestation professionnels qui
montrent qu'effectivement on doit
pouvoir rentrer chez soi aller au
travail ou travailler non seulement il
faudra l'attestation numérique ou papier
mais en plus ce justificatif de son
entreprise
ou sa carte professionnelle lorsqu'on
est infirmière libérale aux journalistes
par exemple
voilà ce que je voulais dire en quelques
mots évidemment il ya des sanctions qui
sont appliquées au moment où les gens ne
respectent pas d interdiction de ce
couvre-feu de 21h à 6h qui ne s'applique
que dans les zones évoquées par monsieur
le premier ministre
une amende de 135 euros et la même
amende que pendant le confinement et si
jamais il devait y avoir réitération
c'est au bout de trois fois les
policiers ou les gendarmes arrivent à
confondre une personne qui par trois
fois fraude ou ne respecte pas ces
règles d'interdiction six mois
d'emprisonnement possible et 3750 euros
d'amendé
par ailleurs évidemment j'ai demandé aux
policiers aux gendarmes sous l'autorité
de monsieur produisent c'est respecter
des règles qui concernent les
établissements notamment les
établissements qui reçoivent du public
effectivement de pouvoir intervenir de
façon vigoureuse
lorsque notamment dans les zones les
plus à risque mais aussi dans toutes les
zones
d'autres zones en france nous avons ce
sujet de regroupement intempestifs dans
des lieux qui ne respectent pas les
règles sanitaires et qui reçoivent du
public et la règle des six évidemment
une règle incitatives pour lequel les
policiers les gendarmes continueront à
faire de la pédagogie évidemment plus
proche de la population
merci monsieur mise intérieur les
contrôles seront donc renforcées voilà
pour les territoires où le couvre feu
sera applicable dans les autres
territoires que ceux où il s'appliquera
les préfets continuerons à adapter les
règles en fonction des réalités
épidémique mais des mesures générales
s'appliqueront partout puisque tout le
territoire national sera désormais
placée en état d'urgence sanitaire
ces règles qui s'appliqueront partout
sont les suivantes toutes les fêtes
privées comme les mariages ou les
soirées étudiantes qui se tiennent dans
des salles des fêtes dans des salles
polyvalentes ou tout autre établissement
recevant du public seront interdites
tous les restaurants de france
impliqueront le protocole sanitaire qui
a été récemment renforcées et prévoient
notamment la limitation à 6 du nombre de
clients par table
et l'enregistrement du nom des clients
pour faciliter le contact racing dans
tous les lieux
vous êtes assis comme les cinémas les
stades les cirques où les salles de
conférence la règle d'un siège sur deux
devra s'appliquer entre deux personnes
ou entre deux familles ou groupes d'amis
de six personnes au maximum et par
arrêté préfectoral le nombre de
visiteurs sera limité à 1000 ou 5000
personnes selon le niveau de circulation
du virus dans tous les lieux où l'on
circule debout comme les centres
commerciaux et les supermarchés les
musées les foires et salons les zoos le
nombre de visiteurs sera limité sur la
base d'une règle de quatre mètres carrés
par personne et dans la limite du job
fixée par le préfet
là aussi en fonction du niveau de
circulation du virus
il ya donc deux régimes correspondant à
deux situations territoriale des règles
générales s'appliquent en partout dans
le pays et des règles renforcées pour
les métropoles soumise au couvre feu
ces règles je les dis s'appliqueront
pour une durée de quatre semaines et
nous allons demander au parlement de les
prolonger jusqu'à la fin novembre
le temps nous l'espérons de ralentir
l'épidémie est de désengorger notre
système de santé
nous inviterons également les
entreprises et les administrations
publiques à développer le recours au
télétravail dans des conditions que va
vous présenter madame la ministre chargé
du travail
merci monsieur le premier ministre
alors vous savez qu'en entreprise
s'applique un protocole national très
strictes qui prévoit notamment depuis le
1er septembre dernier
l'obligation de port du masque dont tous
les espaces de travail
chloé partager ce protocole est efficace
il n'ya pas de chaîne de contamination
quand on applique ce protocole est ce
protocole est très bien appliqué il y a
eu plus de 50000 contrôle de
l'intervention de l'inspection du
travail
depuis le déconfinement il y a eu
uniquement 300 mises en demeure cela
montre que grâce à ce protocole très
strict des salariés peuvent aller au
travail en toute sécurité comme les noms
ce protocole le recours au télétravail
est un mode d'organisation pertinent
pour réduire la propagation du virus
il permet de limiter les contacts au
travail mais aussi aux abords du lieu de
travail et dans les trajets domicile
travail
sa mise en oeuvre doit respecter un
équilibre entre plusieurs objectifs
tout d'abord éviter la propagation du
virus mais aussi maintenir l'efficacité
des organisations de travail et enfin
prévenir les risques liés à l'isolément
des salariés
cet équilibre doit se construire dans le
dialogue social au sein de l'entreprise
ce matin avec laurent py et rachesky
nous avons réuni les partenaires sociaux
pour faire le point sur la mise en
oeuvre du protocole national en
entreprise et évoquer les adaptations et
y apporter je voudrais souligner que les
échanges ont montré un très fort une
très forte responsabilité de la part de
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux mais
également le constat partagé sur
l'efficacité du protocole nous avons
décidé d'apporter de modifications
principales au protocole national
il est désormais demandé aux entreprises
et tout particulièrement à celles qui
sont dans les zones où s'appliquent
le couvre-feu de définir un nombre de
jours minimal de télétravail par semaine
pour les postes qui le permettent et
également d'étaler les horaires
d'arrivée et de départ au travail
les modalités de mise en oeuvre par
exemple le nombre de jours de
télétravail doit faire l'objet d'un
dialogue social au sein d'entreprises
nous souhaitons rendre ces modifications
donc ce nouveau protocole applicable dès
la semaine prochaine dont nous avons
demandé aux partenaires sociaux nous
faire part de leurs observations dans la
journée pour une mise en ligne du
nouveau protocole dès demain s'agissant
de la fonction publique
sur l'ensemble du territoire et chaque
fois que
la pourra être conciliée avec les
nécessités du service
les administrations définiront dès la
semaine prochaine une organisation du
travail intégrant les nécessités du
service et permettant à chaque fois que
cela sera possible
deux à trois jours de télétravail par
semaine mesdames et messieurs l'ensemble
de ces dispositions auront
incontestablement un impact économique
sur les secteurs et les filières
professionnelles concernées nous serons
donc conduit à renforcer et étendre nos
dispositifs d'appui et de soutien dans
la continuité des réponses que nous
avons su apporter depuis le début de la
crise
face à l'urgence économique et social un
plan d'urgence économique a été mis en
oeuvre
le savez afin de protéger les salariés
par le dispositif de chômage partiel le
plus ambitieux d'europe de soutenir la
trésorerie des entreprises par le fonds
de solidarité
le dispositif des prêts garantis par
l'état et les reports et exonérations de
cotisations sociales et de limiter la
persistance des effets de la crise sur
l'appareil productif et les compétences
au cours des dernières semaines le
gouvernement a pris des mesures
complémentaires pour renforcer ce
soutien en direction des entreprises
impactées directement ou indirectement
par les mesures de freinage prises dans
les grandes métropoles et à la demande
du président république nous allons
encore adapté et renforcer ces
dispositifs dans le cadre de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire que nous venons de
décréter ces mesures seront préparés et
concertée avec les professionnels par
les ministres concernés
au premier rang desquels bruno le maire
ministre en charge de l'économie à qui
je cède la parole
merci monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs comme le premier
ministre vient de l'indiquer depuis le
début de cette crise nous avons été aux
côtés des entrepreneurs comme des
salariés touchés par la crise économique
et par les règles de sécurité sanitaire
et nous continueront à l'être après l
annonce de ce couvre-feu
j'ai eu l'occasion en ce matin de
discuter avec l'ensemble des
responsables du secteur de l'hôtellerie
la restauration des cafés de la culture
de l'événementiel et je veux leur dire
que je mesure parfaitement leur désarroi
il avait commencé à se redresser il
avait commencé à rouvrir et ses
obligations sanitaires leur font l'effet
d'une douche froide
nous serons à leurs côtés et nous
continuerons à être leur côté en
renforçant à la demande du président de
la république et du premier ministre
les dispositifs qui sont déjà en vigueur
tout ce qui doit être fait sera fait
pour leur permettre de passer ces
semaines de couvre feu avec un impact
économique le plus réduit possible
nous allons d'abord renforcer une
nouvelle fois simplifiée et élargir le
fonds de solidarité
toutes les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés qui sont installés dans les
zones de couvre-feu et qui ont perdu 50
% de leur chiffre d'affaires par rapport
à 2019 pourront bénéficier d'une aide
allant jusqu'à 1500 euros et cela
pendant toute la durée du couvre-feu
ça veut dire très concrètement que nous
rétablissons le fonds de solidarité pour
toutes les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés quel que soit le secteur auquel
appartiennent c'est le filet de sécurité
que nous mettons en place pour toutes
les entreprises situées dans le
périmètre du couvre-feu
deuxième élément sur le fonds de
solidarité pour les entreprises de moins
de 50 salariés des secteurs de
l'hôtellerie et cafés de la restauration
de la queue
sur de l'événementiel du sport les
fameux secteur s1 et est un bis tels
qu'ils ont été élargis par le premier
ministre nous ne rouvrons l'aide du
fonds de solidarité qui va jusqu'à 10000
euros par mois pour ces secteurs
dès lors qu'elles subissent une perte de
chiffre d'affaires non plus de 70% mais
2 50%
c'est donc un élargissement significatif
pour les entreprises qui perdrait non
plus 70 mais 50% leur chiffre d'affaires
troisième élément sur le fond de
solidarité comme le président de la
république l'avait indiqué hier soir
nous allons améliorer le dispositif du
plafonnement
vous savez que jusqu'à présent
l'ensemble de ces aides du dispositif de
fonds solidarité est plafonné à 60 % du
chiffre d'affaires pour toutes les
entreprises concernées
nous supprimons à compter de samedi le
plafonnement à 60% du chiffre d'affaires
de cette aide pour le secteur de
l'hôtellerie des cafés de la
restauration les secteurs s1 et s2 bis
ces trois modifications du fonds de
solidarité voulue par le premier
ministre et le président de la
république constitue une aide très
significative pour tous les secteurs
touchés par les nouvelles restrictions
sanitaires
le deuxième élément ce sont les
exonérations de charges qui ont
constitué comme vous le savez un les
dispositifs très puissant de soutien aux
secteurs économiques
toutes les entreprises fermées
administrativement bénéficieront d'une
exonération totale leurs cotisations
sociales patronales jusqu'à la fin du
couvre-feu
les entreprises du secteur hôtellerie
cafés restauration qui sont installés
dans les zones de couvre-feu que vient
de signaler le premier ministre pourront
également bénéficier d'une exonération
totale de cotisations sociales
patronales
dès qu'elles perdent 50 % de leur
chiffre d'affaires
il reste les cotisations sociales
salariales puisque je parlais des
cotisations sociales patronales
nous apporterons pour ses cotisations
sociales salariales une aide jusqu'à 20%
la masse salariale qui permet en réalité
de couvrir totalement le poids des
charges sociales
les entrepreneurs concernés les mesures
que nous prenons avec le prêt ministe
permettent de couvrir totalement le
poids des charges sociales pour les
entrepreneurs concernés l'ensemble de
ces mesures seront inscrites dans le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale de 2021 et l'ensemble
de ces mesures
exonération de charges et renforcement
du fonds de solidarité représente un
coût pour les finances publiques d'un
milliard d'euros sur la durée du
couvre-feu
troisième élément les prêts garantis par
l'état qui comme vous le savez sont
aussi un des éléments qui depuis le
début du mois de mars apporte un soutien
massif à l'économie 120 milliards
d'euros de prêts garantis par l'état ont
été déjà délivrés il ya également des
prêts garantis et à saison très
important pour le secteur de
l'hôtellerie et de la restauration
puisque leur plafond n'est plus fixé à
25% du chiffre d'affaires mais aux trois
meilleurs mois de l'année 2019
ce qui est beaucoup plus avantageux pour
ces entreprises de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration parce que ça peut
représenter jusqu'à 80 ou 90% leur
chiffre d'affaires puisque trois mois ça
peut représenter tout simplement la
saison d'été eh bien ces prêts garantis
par l'état qui était disponible jusqu'au
31 décembre de cette année 2020 seront
désormais accessibles jusqu'au 30 juin
c'est donc une prolongation de six mois
de ses prêts garantis par l'état
là aussi comme l'indiqué le présent de
la république hier soir deuxième élément
très significatif ces prêts garantis par
l'état vous savez que beaucoup
d'entreprises souhaitent pouvoir
reporter le remboursement de ces prêts
parce qu'elle se dise on arrive au bout
de ces prêts il va falloir les
rembourser on ne peut pas et bien nous
demandons la fédération bancaire
française d'examiner un report de
remboursement de ces prêts pour une
année supplémentaire pour les
entreprises qui en ont réellement besoin
la souplesse doit être la règle en la
matière j'ai eu l'occasion d'échanger
dès ce matin avec philippe brassac le
président de la fédération bancaire
française et directeur général du crédit
agricole et je le remercie de sa
compréhension sur le sujet quatrième
élément de soutien à tous les secteurs
économiques touchés par la crise
économique ce sont les prêts directs de
l'est
nous avons mis en place à la demande du
premier ministre
des prêts directs de l'état pour les
entreprises les plus en difficulté ils
sont prolongées jusqu'au 30 juin 2021
ce sont vraiment des prêts qui sont pour
toutes les entreprises qui ont sonné à
toutes les portes qui n'ont pas réussi à
trouver de réponse à leur situation et
qui ont besoin de l'aide directe de
l'état
c'est après directe de l'état nous
allons mettre en place un numéro
téléphonique national unique à bercy qui
sera disponible sous une quinzaine de
jours et qui permettra à une entreprise
pme tpe qui ne trouve absolument aucune
solution d'appeler directement le
ministère de l'économie des finances et
de se renseigner sur ces prêts directs
de l'état comme le premier ministre l'a
indiqué toutes ces mesures immédiates
puissante n'épuise pas les
interrogations des secteurs qui sont
concernés et nous devons donc poursuivre
la consultation poursuivre la
concertation avec elle à la demande du
premier ministre ce vrai donc avec
elisabeth bornes et alain griset les
responsables des secteurs de
l'hôtellerie du café de la restauration
de secteur événementiel du sport pour
examiner avec eux toutes les solutions
qui doivent être apportées à des
demandes spécifiques urgente importantes
qui sont désormais sur la table
j'en cite trois la première ce sont les
loyers c'est un sujet incroyablement
compliqué il ya des grands bailleurs il
ya les petits bailleurs privés
il n'y a pas de solution miracle sur les
loyers mais nous avons une exigence de
résultat sur cette question qui je le
sais inquiète beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
nous sommes prêts à discuter de toutes
les solutions envisageables y compris un
crédit d'impôt pour les bailleurs sur
les congés payés
nous savons avec elisabeth bornes que
c'est une bombe à retardement pour
beaucoup de restaurateurs
nous allons traiter ce sujet avec
elisabeth bornes dans les meilleurs
délais troisième sujet ce sont les
assurances
beaucoup de restaurateurs d'hôteliers
s'inquiète des courriers qu'il reçoive
qui leur indique qu'ils ne pourront plus
être couvert par les risques de pandémie
cela entraîne énormément d'inquiétude
notamment dans le secteur de
l'hôtellerie la restauration
nous finaliserons donc dans les
prochaines semaines un nouveau régime
d'assurance pour les entreprises en cas
de catastrophe sanitaire impliquant une
fermeture administrative chose secteur
de la culture qui lui aussi est très
directement touchés et les théâtres les
salles de cinéma les salles de spectacle
avec l'obligation du couvre-feu à 21h le
premier ministre a demandé d'engager des
discussions dès demain matin avec
roselyne bachelot la ministre de la
culture pour répondre à leurs attentes
et trouver les solutions les plus
adéquates possible en france et qui
concerne les associations je connais
leurs inquiétudes qui ont été signalés
par olivia grégoire elles subissent des
surcoûts qui sont associés à la crise
sanitaire
là aussi nous y répondrons avec holiday
grégoire dans les prochains jours je
vous remercie beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
au delà de la solidarité que nous devons
aux secteurs les plus impactés par le
couvre-feu et les mesures sanitaires
nous nous montrons également et
prioritairement attentif à celles et
ceux de nos compatriotes qui en sont les
premières victimes
je pense d'abord aux plus jeunes j'ai
présenté dès le mois de juillet dans le
cadre du plan de relance
un dispositif un jeune une solution
porté par la ministre chargée de
l'emploi est doté de moyens
exceptionnels
il s'agit d'apporter un fort soutien à
l' embauche que ce soit en contrat de
travail ou en contrat d'apprentissage
avec des primes aux entreprises pour
accélérer leur recrutement de jeunes
on a renforcé de manière massive les
formations qualifiantes orienté vers la
transition écologique et les métiers
d'avenir
deux cent mille places de formation en
plus dès cette rentrée nous avons
également créé 26 mille cinq cents
places nouvelles dans ce qu'on appelle
des formations un ses rentes
enfin parce que certains jeunes ont
décroché et qu'il faut les aider à se
réinsérer
nous avons créé et toutes les
passerelles vers l'activité 300000
parcours et contrat d'insertion vont
être progressivement déployé d'ores et
déjà
certains signes sont encourageants si on
prend l'exemple de l'apprentissage
les premières indications de la rentrée
2020 sont bonnes en dépit de la crise
pour une grande majorité des métiers les
entrées en apprentissage sont stables ou
même en légère hausse par rapport à la
même période de l'année dernière qui
était déjà exceptionnel
cela augmente dans le bâtiment dans la
santé dans l'artisanat et dans d'autres
secteurs encore nous sommes pleinement
mobilisés pour accélérer le déploiement
partout dans les territoires du plan
pour les jeunes qui je le répète est une
des priorités de mon gouvernement je
pense aussi aux publics les plus
fragiles les plus pauvres les plus
vulnérables comme le président de la
république l'a annoncé hier une prime de
150 euros sera versée à chaque personne
bénéficiant du rsa de l'allocation de
solidarité et d ap s'ajouteront à ces
150 euros 100 euros supplémentaires par
enfant
cette aide sera versée avant la fin de
l'année et concernera quatre millions
100 mille foyers
j'aurai d'ailleurs l'occasion de
préciser et de compléter ces mesures ce
samedi à l'occasion de la journée
mondiale du refus de la misère
pour terminer je souhaite revenir sur la
question cruciale de l'adaptation de
notre système de soins à l'épisode très
fort auquel il est déjà confronté et qui
va s'aggraver dans les prochains jours
et les prochaines semaines olivier
veyrat à qui je tiens à rendre un
particulier hommage pour son courage et
sa détermination face à cette crise va
vous faire le point sur ce sujet
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le premier
ministre
quelques points d'étape en complément
des points qui ont été précédemment
discuté lors des précédentes conférences
de presse d'abord sur la question des
tests et pour revenir sur ce qu'a dit le
président de la république hier soir
d'abord nous sommes en train de gagner
la bataille des délais en matière
d'accès aux tests vous savez nous avons
rencontré notre pays comme dans comme
d'autres pays
malgré le fait qu'ils sont telles qu'il
testait énormément grâce à la
mobilisation formidable de l'ensemble de
la filière de biologie en ville comme à
l'hôpital
on a rencontré des délais qui étaient
devenus croissant à l'occasion de la
rentrée des retours de vacances des
retours en entreprise dé retour à
l'école cette bataille des délais nous
sommes en train de la gagner je le
disais avec des chiffres qui en
attestent puisque désormais 91 % des
tests pcr sont rendus en moins de 48
heures un délai médian qui est passé à
un peu plus de 24 heures pour le retour
de ces tests et des barnums ces centres
de textes délocalisé qui ont été mis en
place par les agences régionales de
santé destiné au public prioritaire
c'est barnum ne font pas le plein signe
que la situation est nettement moins
tendue pour tout dire nous sommes
revenus sur des indicateurs de rendu de
l'examen qui sont proches de ceux que
nous rencontrions au cours du mois de
juillet voire début août lorsque les
tensions n'était pas palpable sur le
terrain et pourtant le nombre de tests à
réaugmenter puisque il dépasse à nouveau
les 1 million 300 mille par semaine mais
l'enjeu en matière de tests et le
président de la république en a parlé
hier ce sont ces fameux tests
antigénique je vous rappelle prélèvement
nasopharyngé avec un écouvillon dans le
nez la même chose que celles et ceux
d'entre vous qui rue un examen un pc et
reconnaissent et ensuite au lieu de
l'envoyer à un laboratoire
on peut faire directement les manips sur
place qui vous permettent d'avoir le
résultat entre dix et trente minutes
selon les tests nous avions sans
attendre les recommandations
scientifiques comment des 5 millions de
ces tests antigénique qui sont d'ores et
déjà déployé depuis plusieurs jours dans
l'ensemble des régions françaises et à
bas bruit des expérimentations sont
conduites sur des publics particuliers
comme par exemple des étudiants en
médecine des étudiants en soins
infirmiers
mais aussi des admissions à l'hôpital
aux urgences de certains hôpitaux 5
millions de tests c'est beaucoup mais ça
ne suffit pas et donc nous disposons
désormais de toutes les recommandations
de la haute autorité de santé pour
permettre prochainement aux hôpitaux
mais aussi aux médecins libéraux aux
pharmaciens d'officine aux infirmiers
libéraux de pouvoir acquérir ces tests
ainsi que le matériel de protection
adéquate et de pouvoir réaliser
directement ces prélèvements cela va
prendre un peu de temps du temps
nécessaire pour la formation du temps
nécessaire pour l'organisation du temps
nécessaire pour que les tests arrivent
mais d'ores et déjà nous sommes
pleinement mobilisés sur ce chemin ça ne
remplacera pas les tests pcr et nous
avons toujours besoin de la filière de
biologie mais on peut imaginer
on peut même espérer on peut même
escompter que d'ici à quelques semaines
une personne qui aurait de la fièvre
avec des signes respiratoires puisse
être tester directement chez son médecin
si celui ci participe de ce mouvement de
tests antigénique par ailleurs des
barnums ces fameuses opérations
collectives de tests pourront être
conduites conduit à partir de ces tests
antigénique dans les aéroports par
exemple permettant lorsque les personnes
arrivent sur le territoire national en
provenance d'un pays où le virus circule
beaucoup de disposer de leurs résultats
avant de quitter l'aéroport ce qui est
vous l'admettrez quand même mieux
c'est une innovation qui est en train de
gagner la france comme le reste de
l'europe et nous sommes extrêmement
mobilisés deuxième point rapide sur
l'eau ce qu'on appelle le contact racing
c'est le alerté lorsqu'on contact des
gens qui sont cas positifs pour faire
avec eux le tour de toutes les personnes
qu'ils auraient pu contaminer sans le
savoir les fameux qu'à contacter d'abord
ce qu'on constate tant au niveau de
l'assurance maladie que des agences
régionales de santé que des médecins de
ville qui sont mobilisés sur cette
action de contact et racing fait que la
plupart du temps désormais les cas
contacts ont été informés par les
patients eux-mêmes ce qui est évidemment
bien monsieur qui n'empêche pas de
doublé cela d'un appel pour vérifier que
la mise à l'abri ce qu'on appelait avant
l' isolement se passe dans les
meilleures conditions et que les
personnes ne manque de rien plus de 90%
des patients sont contactés dès les
premières 24 heures signe que le système
qui est mis sous forte tension par le
nombre important de malades plus de
vingt mille par jour
ce système fonctionne toujours et le
prix dans la république a parlé hier du
changement de l'application qui
s'appellera tous antico vide qui était
un pas un changement non qui est un
changement de philosophie qui est un
changement de dimensionnement et qui
sera une application pleinement efficace
pour répondre aux défis que nous pose
l'épidémie cédric au travail
d'arrache-pied comme secrétaire d'état
chargée du numérique et nous aurons la
chance de faire dans quelques jours une
présentation des cette nouvelle
application à qui nous souhaitons
évidemment longue vie un point sur la
situation dans les hôpitaux monsieur le
premier ministre c'est un point
important et on voit effectivement
émergé un certain nombre
d'interrogations vous en avait parlé
pourquoi est ce que vous n'avez pas
augmenter les lits de réanimation dans
le pays on serait pas obligé d'avoir un
couvre-feu si on avait vingt mille ou
trente mille litres et à d'abord et
chacun peut comprendre un anesthésiste
réanimateur ses 11 ans de formation
nous avons supprimé le numerus clausus
il y a deux ans mais auparavant
et bien il y avait des limitations du
nombre de médecins en formation ce qui
est regrettable mais nous avons pris
cette décision il ya deux ans on ne peut
donc pas identifié des médecins
anesthésistes réanimateurs comme cela de
la même manière pour les infirmiers les
aides soignants qui travaillent en
service de réa ce sont des soins très
particulier à faire avec des malades
intubé et ventilé avec d assistance
respiratoire
néanmoins une formation pratique a été
mise évidemment en place depuis la
première vague épidémique
rien que dans les hôpitaux parisiens ce
sont 750 infirmières aides soignantes
qui ont participé à une formation leur
permettant demain si la situation devait
l'exiger de renforcer les effectifs en
service de réanimation mais notre
objectif n'est pas de faire le plein d
réa et notre objectif n'est pas d'avoir
un nombre de réa extensible à l'infini
il faut comprendre que pendant la
première vague pour dix sept mille
patients admis en réanimation il ya eu
trente mille morts ce que nous voulons
c'est empêcher les cas graves et pour un
cas graves en réanimation dont on parle
dans les statistiques
il ya un certain nombre de cas moins
graves parfois cela met quand même perte
du goût et de l'odorat une toux
importante sévère une fatigue résistante
ces symptômes peuvent toucher des gens
qui sont plus jeunes que les personnes
qu'on trouve habituellement dans les
services de réanimation c'est pour ça
qu'il faut vraiment notre philosophie
c'est empêcher les cas graves
et c'est donc être dans la prévention de
l'évolution de cette épidémie
néanmoins je vous le disais nous armons
ce qu'on appelle armes et des lits de
réanimation
nous avons des respirateurs nous avons
des équipements de protection
nous avons des médicaments de
réanimation pour faire face à une vague
plus importante s'il était nécessaire
que la première nous sommes passés de
quelques 5000 lits de réanimation armés
dans notre pays à 5800 lee durable avant
la crise mais si nécessaire et à chaque
fois que c'est nécessaire nous
augmentons les capacités de réanimation
mais comment nous faisons nous
supprimerons des blocs opératoires
nous supprimons des salles de réveil
d'où des programmes en des soins de
chirurgie pour des malades qui en ont
besoin
nous ne pouvons pas retarder les soins
dans notre pays et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut être absolument
attentifs les uns les autres il faut
soutenir nos soignants qui comme vous
l'avez dit monsieur le premier ministre
sont fatigués de cette première vague
qui ont énormément donné qu'ils seront
toujours au rendez vous si la situation
devait l'exiger
je veux les en remercier du fond du
coeur pour cela et je sais que les
français s'associe à cet hommage que je
leur rends à nouveau aujourd'hui mais
nous devons prévenir plutôt que subir
enfin un mot monsieur le premier
ministre sur une question qui se pose
qui était la question des personnes
dites vulnérables les personnes qui sont
atteintes de maladies chroniques parfois
peu sévère parfois plus sévère qu'ils
avaient été éloignés du travail pendant
la première vague
compte tenu du risque que le fait de
sortir de chez elles pouvaient faire
porter sur leur santé une première liste
de personnes qui ont pu retrouver le
travail pour éviter une désinsertion
professionnelle trop longue avait été
mise en place
cet été nous allons faire probablement
évoluer cette liste de manière à
protéger davantage de personnes compte
tenu de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
une discussion à d'ores et déjà commencé
avec les associations responsables des
usagers merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre des solidarités de la santé jeu
je voudrais ajouter que à l'intention
des personnels des établissements de
santé puisque nous savons toutes et tous
que le système de soins tiendra grâce
aux soignantes et aux soignants
quelques dispositions complémentaires
importantes ont été prises d'abord afin
de reconnaître par avance l'engagement
des agents qui seront mobilisés par
nécessité de service dans les jours et
semaines à venir une indemnité
compensatrice de congés annuels ont pris
sera mis en place allant de 110 à 200
euros brut par jour
par ailleurs une enveloppe de 100
millions d'euros sera déléguée aux
agences régionales de santé pour mieux
organiser encore la gestion des
ressources humaines
enfin j'ai décidé d'anticiper le
versement des sommes que nous avons
décidé de verser au personnel en
application du ségur de la santé vous le
savez cet accord historique que j'ai
signé avec les partenaires sociaux
peu de jours après ma prise de fonction
prévoit une revalorisation de plus de
200 euros par mois pour 2 millions de
soignant à l'hôpital et dans les ehpad
au profit des femmes et des hommes et
qui font notre système de santé
il s'est traduit par une première
augmentation salariale de 90 euros par
mois aux mois de septembre et qui pour
certains apparaîtra sur la feuille de
paie d'octobre une deuxième tranche de
93 euros par mois devait intervenir en
mars prochain au regard de la situation
je vous annonce qu'elle interviendra
plus tôt avant la fin de l'année 2020 à
la fois pour reconnaître pour
reconnaître le travail de ces
professionnels et renforcer davantage
encore l'attractivité de ces professions
mesdames et messieurs mes chers
concitoyens
je comprends l'inquiétude voire la
lassitude qui est la vôtre et je dois le
dire je peux la partager mais je suis là
face aux circonstances présentes avec
mon gouvernement pour agir et pour faire
face à la situation difficile que nous
traversons
l'ensemble des mesures que nous
annonçons aujourd'hui seront précisés et
adapté d'ici samedi
nous le ferons dans un cadre concerté
avec les partenaires sociaux avec les
représentants de secteurs professionnels
avec les élus locaux avec lesquels je
suis en lien constant et que je veux
encore remercier avec les partis
politiques et les groupes parlementaires
que je recevrai une nouvelle fois la
semaine prochaine pour notamment évoquer
avec eux l'impact de la dégradation de
la situation sanitaire sur le pays mais
aussi sur l'organisation des prochaines
échéances électorales
beaucoup de questions se règle par
l'écouté et le dialogue nous traversons
un moment inédit de notre histoire un
moment appelé à durer encore plusieurs
mois
et comme toujours dans les moments
difficiles
la tentation est grande de rechercher
les boucs émissaires d'opposer les uns
aux autres de nous perdre dans de vaines
polémiques
le moment viendra lorsque cette crise
sanitaire sera terminée et elle se
terminera d'en tirer sereinement toutes
les conséquences et tous les
enseignements mais pour l'heure toutes
nos énergies doivent être tournés vers
ce combat contre la maladie et sa
propagation
c'est à notre portée si nous restons
solidaires si nous sommes responsables
l'état et le gouvernement dans son
ensemble sont bien entendu en première
ligne pour vous protéger et prendre les
mesures que la situation appelle comme
le font du reste vous l'avez constaté
l'ensemble des autorités politiques des
pays voisins confrontés à des situations
tout à fait comparable mais ce n'est pas
l'état qui frappe c'est le virus c'est
lui notre objectif commun c'est face à
lui que nous devons unir nos forces et
non volonté la france est un grand pays
ensemble nous surmonterons cette épreuve
j'en ai la conviction
nous nous tenons à votre disposition
mesdames et messieurs pour répondre à
vos questions
on va prendre
série de questions comment fait
d'habitude je voulais bien bonjour
camille collin pour tf1 lci
j'ai deux questions sur le couvre feu la
première sur les critères est ce que
d'autres métaux métropole pourrait
basculer en couvre feu est-ce que
l'horaire de 21h pourrait être revu à
20h peut-être c'est si les signaux et
les chiffres la situation empire et dans
certaines métropoles et à quelle
échéance et à linverse est ce qu'une
ville pourrait sortir du couvre feu
avant décembre si les signaux étaient au
vert dans cette ville et puis deuxième
série de questions cette fois sur les
transports vous en parliez tout à
l'heure alors j'ai cru comprendre qu'on
pouvait prendre un train ou un avion
avant 21h est ce qu'on peut en prendre à
eux aussi après 21h est-ce qu'on peut
aller chercher quelqu'un à la gare ou à
l'aéroport qui arriverait dans ses
horaires là et est ce que l'offre de
transport va être amenuisées alors je ne
sais pas sur le train peut-être sur
l'avion dans des métropoles sur les
métro par exemple à paris où les bus de
nuit
merci beaucoup bonjour oui vous en prie
je suis là simon le baron de france
inter première question pouvez-vous
garantir aux français que vous inciter à
les travailler même si bien compris un
certain nombre de jours de télétravail
dans dans certaines entreprises qu'ils
prennent moins de risques dans les
transports en commun qui sont parfois
bondés ou au sein de l'entreprise que
lors d'un dîner avec des amis à la
maison et deuxième question vous l'avez
évoqué monsieur le premier ministre à la
fin de votre intervention sur les
élections régionales un report des
départementales et des régionales de
2021 est il clairement envisagée
j'aimerais me marot de la fp une
question pour le secteur de la culture
un billet de cinéma ticket pour le
théâtre est ce que ça peut faire office
d'attestation et à ce titre peut-on
aménager le couvre-feu voilà pour aider
le secteur culturel qui est très cliché
par
dans la crise adam derrière oui bonjour
julien van aelst pour bfm tv
monsieur le premier des perquisitions
ont eu lieu notamment au domicile de
votre ministre de la santé ce matin est
ce que ces perquisitions ne risque pas
de brouiller votre votre message et est
ce que vous vous accordez à nous faire
est-ce que vous accordez votre confiance
à votre ministre de la santé
au regard de ces perquisitions madame
bonjour bonjour ayant donné pour lci tf1
j'ai une question sur les tests
antigénique quand seront ils disponibles
une autre question sur les jeunes
entreprises parce que vous avez parlé
beaucoup des aides aux entreprises
mais c'est lent créations n'ont pas
forcément de variation de chiffre
d'affaires qu'au va-t-il se passer pour
pour ces jeunes entreprises
et puis un mot sur les effectifs de
policiers mobilisés vous avez dit je
crois 12 mille policiers
est-ce qu'on inclut aussi les gens
dorment nuit
une dernière question a pu encore à un
deuxième loger voulez bien qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ceux qui disent que si
vous avez été obligé de de mettre en
place ce couvre-feu est due à l'échec du
déconfinement bon en fait ce premier lot
je vais donner la parole aux ministres
concernés jeu d'abord je commence quand
on sort dernière question bon si c'est
ça ça veut dire que les stratégies de
déconfinement échoué partout monsieur
parce que il ne vous a pas échappé vous
avez vu les courbes vous connaissez la
situation dans tous les pays voisins ils
sont confrontés alors exactement la même
situation c'est un peut dépendre des
moments certains sont plus en avance
d'autres un peu plus en retard mais
grosso modo le mouvement est exactement
le même
bon donc voilà je je pense d'abord que
les conditions climatiques
incontestablement le fait qu'on rentre
plus chez soi partout en europe
arm est un retour plus facile du virus
peut-être aussi en france comme ailleurs
la période estivale al'inverse après le
confinement qui a été très difficile et
très douloureux pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens ont connu une certaine forme
de relâchement dans le respect des
gestes barrières
voilà donc je veux dire c'est la
perspective d'une deuxième vague en plus
avaient été pointés par par les
scientifiques
donc je ne pense pas que mais je dis ça
avec beaucoup d'humilité et vous savez
c'est une crise inédite chaque pays
s'adapte et donc je ne pense pas encore
une fois que nos stratégies diffèrent
considérablement de celle des pays
étrangers puisque vous évoquez en
particulier la stratégie du
déconfinement qu' edouard philippe
m'avait confié le soin de conduire en
droit de lui proposer
je me souviens que déjà à l'époque nous
avions un club d déconfit nateur des
pays voisins pour comparer les mesures
que les uns les autres adoptions et
encore une fois nous étions un peu près
dans
la même et purent alors je répond
également à la question de bfm sur la
perquisition et mesures qui ont été
prises par la commission d'instruction
de la cour de justice de la république
vous comprendrez tout et tout ce qu'il
ne m'appartient absolument pas de
commenter des décisions d'une autorité
judiciaire a vraiment pas en revanche je
peux tout à fait répondre à votre
deuxième question sur la confiance que
j'accorde à monsieur olivier verront ici
présents sachez qu'elle est totale outre
bien entendu il besoin de rappeler que
sur le volet judiciaire que je ne
connais pas il bénéficie d'une totale
présomption d'innocence mais je voudrais
vous faire mesurer à toutes et à tous
mesdames et messieurs la difficulté de
cette crise sanitaire que nous vivons
avait des hauts et des bas depuis
plusieurs mois olivier ferrand est en
fonction depuis plusieurs mois
matin midi soir la nuit le week-end j'en
atteste devant vous il est toujours au
front toujours au front toujours il ne
ménage ni son temps ni sa grande
compétence et c'est un atout pour notre
pays pour faire face aux événements
sanitaires auxquels nous sommes
confrontés est précisément s'il veut
bien je vais lui donner la parole pour
revenir la première question qui a été
posée sur les critères 20 a dit est ce
que il pourrait y avoir un madame c'est
ça d'autres agglomérations d'autres
territoires qui pourraient être
concernés par les mesures de couvre-feu
vous avez demandé si l'horaire que nous
avons retenu 21h pourrait évoluer c'est
bien ça est également vous avez posé une
question sur la durée
d'application de ce couvre feu avant de
céder la parole à olivier ferrand le
président de la république dit hier soir
je me permets de le rappeler nous avons
déjà en france utiliser cette mesure de
couvre feu je le rappelle c'était en
guyane
je vous rappelle aussi que c'est mon
premier ma première sortie officielle
comme premier ministre avec olivier
ferrand et sébastien lecornu le ministre
en charge des outre-mer où la situation
était extrêmement extrêmement pour
rentrer avec notamment des évacuations
sanitaires vers vers d'autres
territoires ultramarins et se couvre feu
a fait ses preuves
olivier monsieur premier ministre sur
l'évolution des indicateurs du
couvre-feu
la solution qui a été annoncé par le
présent de la république hier et
équilibrée elle permet elle permettra de
lutter efficacement contre la diffusion
du virus ce que nous enseigne le retour
de la première vague et mais également
ce qui se passe chez nos voisins c'est
qu'au fond il faut plusieurs semaines
pour qu'il mesure soit pleinement
efficace
le confinement généralisée dans notre
pays a pu démontrer son efficacité
importante à la fois sur l'évolution de
l'épidémie est à la fois sur l'évolution
des cas graves en trois semaines c'est à
dire qu'il faut quand même de la
patience et vous savez pourquoi pas ce
que vous voyez cette courbe qui fait le
lien entre les contaminations et les cas
graves en moyenne deux à trois semaines
donc de toute façon il faut du temps et
de la patience
ensuite le choix qui est opéré c'est un
choix proportionnée territorialisée
différencier pourquoi parce qu'on
n'applique pas les mêmes mesures dans un
territoire où le virus circule peu et
oui circule de façon très importante
c'est aussi une différence par rapport à
la première vague et c'est pourquoi oui
certains territoires pourrait rejoindre
la liste des des territoires
actuellement et qui seront bientôt sous
couvre-feu sanitaire c'est possible et
oui s'il y avait des évolutions
importantes importante et durable
objective et dans certains territoires
nous pourrions alors nous reposer la
question en conseil de défense et de
sécurité nationales de savoir s'il faut
ou non rebasculer un territoire vers une
zone qui aurait moins de contraintes
sanitaires ça me paraît absolument
essentiel sur les tests antigénique
j'avais répondu madame tout à l'heure
sur le déploiement en disant qu'ils
adhéraient à 5 millions qui sont en
cours de déploiement mais que vous ne
voyez pas parce que c'est fait dans des
secteurs très particulier mais c'est
très utile et le déploiement général va
se faire semaine après semaine à compter
à compter de maintenant et puis enfin un
dernier mot pour dire monsieur le
ministre la de vous remercier pour vos
mots dire que moi j'ai confiance dans
les français j'ai confiance en le
soignant et que c'est ça qui compte
merci beaucoup il ya eu deux questions
sur les transports
figurant la ville un petit peu plus de
15h merci d'être avec nous en ce jeudi
15 octobre
on a suivi ensemble les détails du
couvre-feu et le détail les nouvelles
mesures annoncées par emmanuel macron
hier avec le chef du gouvernement un
jean castex qui étaient là entouré de
plusieurs ministres dont ceux de
l'intérieur de l'économie ou encore de
la santé oms va décrypter ce ensemble en
direct sur twitter bonjour à léa passion
captain mika ou encore napolitain merci
d'être avec nous je vois que vous avez
pas mal de questions bonjour également
sur youtube et sur lefigaro.fr où je
vois gérard chris kraus ou encore nous
jusqu'à si vous avez des réactions des
questions j'en ai relevé déjà quelques
unes poster les on va débriefer dans
quelques instants avec tristan v du
service santé médecine sciences médecine
du figaro
mais avant on va se tourner vers
jean-marc leclerc qui est rédacteur en
chef adjoint au service société du
figaro jean marc bonjour merci d'être
avec nous on va parler de ce couvre-feu
et de ses modalités 21h06 heures à
partir de la nuit de vendredi à samedi
en ile de france et dans huit métropoles
le retour des attestations pour se
déplacer si on a un motif impérieux des
médicaments à les acheter une
consultation médicale si on rentre du
travail si on doit sortir son animal de
compagnie aussi le retour des
attestations donc le retour des amendes
aussi de 135 euros
si on ne respecte pas ça j'ai conscience
de la lassitude a dit il ya quelques
instants le chef du gouvernement qu'elle
est tout simplement jean-marc le niveau
d'acceptabilité des français de ses 20
millions de français en tout cas
concernés à l'heure actuelle par se
couvre
il a indéniablement plus faible qu'au
moment du confinement
voilà donc tout va être une question de
doigté pour les membres des forces de
l'ordre qui vont être au quotidien
confrontés à des situations concrètes
voilà c'est dit évidemment qu'il va
varier d'un territoire à un autre
évidemment c'est tout le problème les
français ont un grand sens de l'équité
et donc de ce qui se passe dans le
jardin du voisin est donc évidemment ça
va être difficile d'expliquer aux gens
qu'ils sont soumis à des règles strictes
d'un côté mais que de l'autre côté de la
barrière et bien on vit tranquille elle
sans avoir à justifier ça va être assez
difficile oui ça va ça va peut-être
occasionné d'ailleurs des petits
mouvements de population des gens qui
vont changer peut-être de territoire
c'est possible et concrètement du goût
alors vous voir il ya encore une dépêche
qui est tombé un peu longtemps un
policier a été blessé par un chauffeur
lors d'un contrôle routier c'était cette
nuit à mitry mory en seine-et-marne en
détention y sont absolument cette de
forces de l'ordre épuisés on parle des
personnes hospitalisées
épuisé mais aussi les forces de l'ordre
qui ont plus en plus de mal semble-t-il
en tout cas sur certains territoires à
faire respecter
alors je sais pas quel tellement qu'elle
soit excusé mais je pense qu'elles sont
exaspérés ça c'est sûr parce
qu'évidemment la violence au quotidien
s'exerce le contre elle dans certains
territoires
elle aimerait être davantage soutenus
par le gouvernement il ya eu des
annonces qui ont été faites là on est en
train de passer un peu de pommade parce
qu'on sait qu'on va avoir besoin d'elle
et donc oui ça dépend des territoires
comme toujours c'est une question de
territoire
les policiers disent grosso modo faire
appliquer le confinement dégradée en
quelque sorte dans des quartiers bien
intégré pas de soucis mais par contre à
la courneuve à champigny sur marne ou
ailleurs c'est pas la même farine ça va
être beaucoup plus compliqué c'est
tellement vrai d'ailleurs que c'est à
champigny sur marne que et pendant leur
confinement qu'on a inventé cette mode
du tir de de mortiers de feux d'artifice
sur la police enfin bref les délinquants
ou où les où les jeunes ne plus disons
plus agressif que la moyenne
et bien cela ont plutôt tendance
effectivement à prendre l'offensive face
à la police ça c'est quand même un petit
peu nouveau est ce qu'il y aura des
transferts
d'effectifs vers les zones les plus
sensibles notamment en ile de france
de toute façon il y aura certainement
des renforts il y aura douze mille
policiers et gendarmes dit on parce que
futur être prudent avec les chiffres
annoncés en matière de couverture du
terrain par les forces de l'ordre
mais visiblement effectivement il va y
avoir quand même des dispositifs un peu
concentrés voilà alors bon ce sera plus
facile d'aller taper à la porte d'un
appartement du 6e arrondissement
que dalle et voilà dans une barre où on
reçoit d'ordinaire des réfrigérateurs et
des boules de pétanque
on a une question sur tweets chez ce que
l'armée participent au couvre-feu dans
la c police et gendarmerie
non non les gendarmes bien sûr tiennent
à leur statut militaire mais on peut pas
les présenter comme des militaires ce
jour-là donc non non l'art mais on n'en
est pas là heureusement enfin sur les 10
ils sont utiles pour tout le travail
antiterroriste à les patrouilles
habituelles donc ils sont quand même sur
le terrain dans les grandes villes
le couvre feu alors on a l'impression de
découvrir ce mot là ce matin mais
finalement on l'a déjà eu est justement
là déjà eu par exemple en 2005 lors des
vielle ensemble alors qu'ils ont classé
différents en fait en france on se rend
compte d'une chose c'est que l'appareil
est en fait policiers il est sous
dimensionné ou mal organisés pour
pouvoir maintenir un tel niveau de
pression sécuritaire sur des territoires
en tout cas sur l'ensemble du territoire
c'est sûr on n'y arrive pas au bout
d'une dizaine de jours en 2005 dans les
émeutes le système était le système
était à bout de souffle
on savait plus où trouver les réserves
pour voir renouveler les troupes
fraîches tellement c'était difficile
mais ce n'était pas le même contexte
c'était dans le cadre d'une véritable
guérilla urbaine qui se livrait dans
quasiment toutes les grandes
conurbations là on est dans le cadre
d'actions qui vont être sans doute un
peu compliqué un peu conflictuelle dans
certains points de concentration des
villes mais ce ne sera pas la bataille
rangée sans doute comme on a pu
connaître au moment des émeutes de 2005
mais ce sera difficile sûrement est ce
qu'on peut s'attendre à ce que les
forces de police bah finalement soit
peut-être un peu encombré od au
téléphone par des des résidus de
conflits de voisinage c'est à dire
j'entends une fête chez mon voisin
j'appelle pour le dénoncer on a attendu
c'est un peu pourri filmant oui
évidemment il
à voir il va y avoir des comportements
qu'on connaît bien pendant les périodes
difficiles
oui la police vide informations pour se
déplacer donc il ya des gens qui vont
certainement informés alors animée de
bonnes ou de mauvaises intentions ça
c'est dit c'est au cas par cas
c'est là qu'il faut justement un sens
aigu de l'appréciation chez les ch'tis
chef de police dans les secteurs mais en
tout cas oui effectivement il y aura des
dénonciations il y aura des déplacements
de police il y aura des contraventions
voilà la seule chose c'est qu'on l'a vu
bons débuts real anticriminalité qui
était requise pour montrer comme comme
la police est offensif sur ces questions
là évidemment on va pas refaire ce n'est
la police dit féminité aux portes de
tous les appartements qui pose problème
voilà je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de
discipline sur laquelle la police compte
enfin quelques exemples on verra après
si elle et quelques sanctions qui vont
tomber sur ont assez dissuasives pour
discipliner tout le monde et pas
question très concrète de jean marc et
après on va retourner dans le chat et on
va surtout vous laisser puisque vous
avez pas mal d'articles à écrire mais
tout simplement est ce que si les
policiers les forces de l'ordre sans tu
deviens sentent qu'il ya une soirée est
organisée comme ça on aperçoit un
premier étage est-ce qu'ils ont les
moyens légaux d'intervenir chez les gens
ce que là on entre dans la sphère privée
oui mais on est quand même dans le cadre
d'une infraction caractérisée donc
toute cette affaire là ça va être une
affaire de doigté ça va être au cas par
cas c'est ça dépend de l'intelligence de
comportement du responsable de l'unité
de terrain certains vont se comporter de
manière tout à fait irréprochable
peut-être que d'autres un peu moins ça
se saura rapidement de toute façon je
pense que voilà la prison leur public a
fait appel au bon sens je crois que ce
serait une mesure de bon sens je pense
que c'est un message qui s'adresse aux
professionnels
voilà merci beaucoup jean marc leclerc
d'avoir appris ce temps pour débriefer
avec nous en direct sur figaro live
après les les
les mesures les précisions dévoile
dévoilé par jean castex et quelques
instants vous voyez que la conférence de
presse est toujours en cours il ya
également le ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance bruno le maire
qui est en train de s'exprimer jean-marc
le car j'en fais que vous êtes rédacteur
en chef adjoint au service société merci
beaucoup et on va se tourner à présent
vers tristan v on va basculer du côté du
service santé médecine de sciences
médecine pardon du figaro tristan on va
avec vous évoquez le volet plus
sanitaire médicale le volet hospitalier
aussi qu'est ce que vous retenez un des
précisions à l'instant du chef du
gouvernement et des ministres pour te
dire on n'a pas eu un bon jour a tous
déjà on n'a pas eu beaucoup beaucoup
d'éclaircissements par rapport à la
nature l'épidémie coûts par rapport à la
création d'aidés soignants oui ces
annonces de la reconnaissance du travail
des soignants avec avec des primes
et puis d'expliquer aux gens du fait que
vous ne pouvez pas compter sur une
extension des délits de réanimation
encore une fois je pense que ce que je
retiens aussi c'est que aux yeux vairons
a parlé en berne et dans cette
conférence de presse et que d'une
certaine manière
si on veut convaincre les gens et et
obtenir leur adhésion il faut leur
expliquer pourquoi on prend les mesures
comprend une question et je suis pas
certain que sur la bonne la bonne
méthode de commencer par expliquer
une mission avant d'expliquer les
raisons pour lesquelles on fait les
choses macro hier avait bien expliqué
qui va la moitié des gens qui avaient
moins de 25 ans qui était en réagi pense
était une très bonne chose de commencer
par size del en préambule et j'ai trouvé
voilà oliveira un petit peu construit
sur le sujet je pense qu'il aurait été
bon de rappeler très rapidement voilà
l'extraction des déplaçant real n'est
pas une vraie solution ça permet juste
le 2e but de diminuer un peu le 18
l'attend si on veut mais on aurait
attendu trois semaines de plus il aurait
fallu reprendre des mesures ce que
l'épidémie s'arrête pas d'elle même est
ce que finalement oliveira n'était pas
un peu emprunté avec ce qui s'est passé
ce matin perquisition à son bureau à son
domicile tout comme au bureau et au
domicile de deshors philippe d'agnès
busin c'est une information judiciaire
qui a été ouverte par la cour de justice
de la république sur la gestion de cette
épidémie
ce qui est peut-être un lien finalement
j'ai je suis difficile à dire je connais
pas les détails des perquisitions
comment elles sont déroulés je peux
comprendre qu'elle s'était déroulée tout
de manière calme à une beaucoup de
coopération dans un vous préfecture
juridiques étaient déclenchées par des
plaintes jeu je suis enfin je pense pas
que les perquisitions en elle-même soit
le signe nécessairement d'une
culpabilité
il ya des besoin d'éclaircissements de
comprendre comment les choses ont été
menées sans fait je pense pas que ce
soit que ça ait influé sur sa prestation
je le problème de communication il est
peu profond ça et plus
il a depuis longtemps il ya une espèce
de frilosité à dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont c'est à dire que rien d'où
on aurait pu dire dès début juillet nous
on l'a fait au figaro mais on le sait
une gouvernement le dit et que c'est
repris par tous les médias et c'est
juste un journal le 10 avec la même
chose mais qu'on avait un doublement des
90 jours et qu à ce rythme là on serait
en difficulté mi octobre
bon c'est un hasard de calendrier on est
on est le 15 octobre mais on était déjà
en difficulté ya deux semaines à
expliquer aux gens que le nombre de cas
augmente sans organisation parce qu'il
ya un retard et celle des
sur les jeunes sont contaminés et des
manières de le dire beaucoup plus clair
que ce qui a été fait et aujourd'hui je
pense que de manière assez claire
d'expliquer que les morts s'accumulent
et considéré à commence à saturer il y
aura des morts de moins de 65 ans qui ne
serait pas mort serena n'avait pas été
saturé et c'est ça le l'enjeu et je
comprends pas pourquoi on ne dit pas
clairement les une espèce de 2,2 pudeur
a pas vouloir parler de de la mort ne
pas vouloir parler de mauvaise nouvelle
mais c'est je pense ce qui est ce qui
est peut-être nécessaire pour la prise
de conscience
donc voilà le le couvre-feu d'ailleurs
sur le plan sanitaire
est-ce qu'il est utile ou pas c'est que
c'est compliqué à démontrer parce que
partout il était mis en oeuvre il l'a
été avec d'autres mesures donc faire la
distinction de la part du couvre feu ce
qui est la part du durcissement des
autres restrictions elle est difficile à
faire et je pense qu'ils noueraient
volonté de créer un électrochoc chez des
populations qu'elles prennent conscience
de la gravité de la situation et je
pense qu'il ya eu d'autres manières de
le faire depuis depuis plusieurs
semaines etc voilà il est le
gouvernement n'a pas été aidé par parler
tous les experts assurent east qu'on a
pu voir parfaite partout qui proclamait
que le virus était à 10 minutes et était
moins dangereux qui avait moins de morts
qu'il n'y a pas de spécialisation que
c'est une fausse deuxième dax 10 pour
faire peur aux gens
on avait tous les hits tous les outils
épidémiologique oui pour expliquer ce
qui était un fonds se passer et ce qui
allait se produire et je vois là je
pense qu'on peut regretter ça et là
encore le manque de pédagogie de cette
conférence de presse je trouvé
regrettable
on regrette vraiment le temps il dort
fille pour tout n'était pas rose pour la
première vague mais je pense que
l'effort de pédagogie qui avait eu à
l'époque avait été singulièrement plus
important c'est vrai qu'entre temps
ministre de l'intérieur a changé le
premier ministre a changé ministre du
travail également même si gérald
darmanin elisabeth bornes étaient déjà
dans le gouvernement le chef du
gouvernement jean castex qui a appuyé le
ton et qui a insisté sur un le nom à la
déprogrammation massive des des
opérations dans l'impression que au delà
des réanimations et des morts liés au co
vide
on parle de plus en plus si ce n'est
au même niveau autant de sept noms des
programmations des opérations oui
c'était ce qu'on appelait le contrecoup
delà de la première vague tous et des
programmations
il ya eu beaucoup de rattrapage pendant
l'été mais les soignants sont à bout ils
ont pas eu de pause tout le monde a eu
un répit estival dans les hôpitaux ça
tout été le cas parce qu'il y avait un
gros rattrapage de tout ce qui avait été
reporté pour la première vague dans une
situation où non seulement un reporter à
nouveau sur des opérations pourraient
mettre les les patients en difficulté
avec des pertes de chances accrues
d'autre part des personnels soignants
qui sont qui sont à bout et sur lesquels
à qui on va avoir du mal à demander de
refournir le même fort qu'après un wagon
de la ligue et cette fois ci prendre un
peu plus tôt avec un virus qui circule
heureusement un peu moins vite en bas à
la louche deux fois moins vite
aujourd'hui ou lors de la première vague
voilà est-ce que c'est voir il faut
espérer que c'était pas simplement un
ralentissement dit il ya une
saisonnalité et qu'il y avait un
véritable effet des masques des gestes
barrières de du télétravail etc et que
ça ça pue ça s'appelait jour la
dynamique c'est simplement un effet
saisonnier que le virus se retrouve la
rapidité qu'il avait avant ça va être
beaucoup beaucoup plus gros film
compliqué de de piloter et l'enjeu 2-2
d'éviter l'engorgement des réseaux au
niveau de la première vague est d'autant
plus important pour se laisser un peu de
marche alors il ya certaines la marge
qui permet de lui permet de mener les
opérations courantes mais il ya aussi la
marche 2 voilà si jamais pour une raison
ou une autre le lean accélération il
faut quand même avoir un peu de un peu
de visibilité un petit peu de réserve on
pourra pas tenir très longtemps
inscris toi là et s'en veut par confiner
ça veut dire laisser des gens mourir
parce qu'ils n'ont pas pu être réanimé
jeu
l'objet du gouvernement c'est d'avoir à
tout prix à être confronté à ce dilemme
une question qui revient sur lefigaro.fr
sur les chiffres les chiffres actuels
tristan c'est bien ça on a cinq mille
lits de réanimation disponible à l'heure
actuelle oui c'est ça un peu plus sa
différence à nous de 5800 lee harnais si
j'ai bien compris on a vu en été montés
je crois 7005 ou humilie par la première
vague donc c'est toujours possible mais
ça veut dire en gros c'est très simple à
s'apprendre délit ailleurs qui sont des
blocs opératoires ou des environnements
compatible avec des opérations de
réanimation pour les consacrer à
l'animation donc ça veut dire renoncer
inde autre chose donc même si on peut
commander des capacités une forme de
souplesse elle se fait au détriment
d'autres choses et et là je crois qu un
éleveur a enfin eu raison de le rappeler
je ne sais pas une fin en soi d'être en
capacité d'accueillir les gens en
réanimation le but c'est quand même
d'éviter qu'ils y arrivent alors et pour
ça la seule manière comment on peux pas
anticiper qui va terminer en réa moment
on est obligé d'être collectivement
collectivement de faire un effort en
attendant qu'ils en aient des
traitements plus efficaces et ou un bac
ça ou les deux le tiers de ces lits sont
occupés à l'heure actuelle d'après les
dernières données qui nous sont fournis
est ce que chacun de ces lits de
réanimation tristan son sont équipés
d'un respirateur
à ma connaissance je pense que oui après
on est beaucoup beaucoup de gens en
réanimation du canton et qu'on évite
d'un tube hey hey combien s'oxygéner
oxygénothérapie à haut débit kim
président moins invasive par le nez mais
ça reste des gens qui sont considérés en
ré à la réalisation mégane n'équivaut
pas automatiquement l'inter mais oui on
a commandé beaucoup de respirateurs je
pense pas qu'il a ce jour il n'y a pas
de n'y a pas de personnes on nous
signale de pénurie spécial ce qu'on voit
là il faut savoir quand on dit 30 %
d'occupation d'airé à 60 d'occupation
par des patients qu'aux vide
ça veut dire que l'airé à elles sont
qu'à une plein d'autres gens le
d'accidentés de la route de gens qui ont
des des opérations lourdes et grèves
dès qu'ils sont opérés pour des raisons
des cancers le l'aîné il ya beaucoup de
ré en france qui sont déjà à plus de 100
% de taux d'occupation dont 30 40 50 60
% dans le vide c'est pas il n'ya pas il
faut pas s'imaginer que les real ya 30%
de un tir d'élite qui sont pris et les
deux tiers qui sont en vie dans les tous
les dix on s'en occuper c'est juste
qu'ils sont pris à un tiers par deux
passions que vide et c'est ça aussi le
même caractère exceptionnel mais jamais
jamais jamais il ya 30% denis de
gastines occupés par des gens qui ont la
grippe et ça c'est une information vous
parlez de clarté de l'information
justement qu'on comprend pas forcément
tout de suite un finalement non je pense
qu'il ya un vrai il est vrai frilosité
jeu que je m'explique mal alors soit
parce que ça me paraît évident au sein
de la santé soit parce qu'ils se disent
que les gens comprennent pas ou sont pas
en cap c'est de comprendre il faut pas
leur faire peur je je maîtrise mal les
raisons profondes je crois qu'il ya un
énorme défaut de communication depuis le
début les autorités de santé publique
que soit la dgs santé publique france le
ministère ont des difficultés à
communiquer je ne crois pas qu'il y ait
volonté de masquer quoi que ce soit
c'est ça qui est qui et qui est triste
il ya un problème de communication
ce matin on a appelé la dgs le temps
d'attenté pour savoir si oliveira
faisait son son point hebdomadaire on
n'a pas su nous répondre on n'a pas su
nous dire oui à parler à 14h avec avec
jean castex
il a fallu attendre plus de deux ccc à
cc des petites choses qui s'accumulent
systématique des coûts va voir un
chiffre d pour veut avoir
voilà donc c'est assez compliqué le les
indicateurs qui change tous les mois
la stratégie a l'air d'être assez isolé
qui de visant à tester alerte et
protéger sa voilà c'est tout change sans
qu'on comprenne bien pourquoi les
indicateurs de
de couleur les données utilisées par
santé publique france et les cartes de
deux vulnérabilités de sertic france ne
sont pas les mêmes que les niveaux d'
alerte sur la santé voilà c'est tout ça
et manque de cohérence donc de clarté
manque de visibilité et sa compagne de
messages ensuite de santé publique qui
sont très compliqués à entendre demandez
aux gens de comprendre qu'on leur dise
de porter des masques dans la rue mais
qu'en même temps en temps dans un lieu
fermé qui va porter des masques aéré
comment est ce qu'on peut entendre ça
comment est ce qu'on peut entendre qu'
il faut pas se réunir en famille ou à
l'aéro storm et qu'on peut aller
travailler manger à la cafétéria sans
problème et pendant pour h pas massives
ont été travaillés ccc c'est dur à
entendre alors je dis pas que les
mesures on a lui-même sont mauvaises
elles sont très difficiles et des
arbitrages économiques à l affaire qui
sont importants je pense qu'il doit y
avoir un effort de pédagogie plus
important on le voit la typiquement vrai
à dire que les dire que les transports
sont si on ne sont pas dangereux du tout
parce qu'il ya peu de clusters tout en
disant que l'école n'y a pas de problème
alors que il ya 30 ou 40 ans avec nos
stocks eia on voit bien qu'il ya quelque
chose qui ne va pas dans dans cette
communication qui est pas audible
derrière il ya des raisons qui peuvent
l'expliquer mais si on ne les explique
pas si on n'explique pas que voilà on
fait un choix en fait le choix
d'éducation parce que c'est très
important et ça l'est par rapport à la
santé publique et que du coup on
s'autorise quelques par des dépassements
sur secteur là c'est je pense que les
gens peuvent longtemps il faut leur dire
voilà il faut pas les prendre pour des
cons des pour des imbéciles quoi c'est
une réaction aussi sûr
lefigaro.fr avec nos internautes pragma
qui nous dit j'ai travaillé en chu le
nombre de places en réa est ridicule
dans la plupart des chu il a été aussi
question des tests dans la prise de
parole d'olivier véran les tests
antigénique qui pourrait être bientôt
disponible chez les médecins
mais là on n'a pas non plus d'ordre
d'idées un concernant le la période de
mise en place d'éventuelles périodes de
mise en place d'ailleurs oui ces
quelques semaines on sait pas comprend
pas très bien combien de test à qui
seront adressées et c'est donc voila
voila le la politique n'est pas encore
très clair après c'est des choses qui
sont assez
qui sont ils existent depuis longtemps
ces tests pour le nikkei beaucoup
beaucoup de temps avant avant de les
mettre en place
quand j'ai lu le manque d'éléments
aujourd'hui serait bien avant des tests
n'a plus rapidement vivant a dit qu'on
faisait des progrès sur les rangs du
tout tout enfin juge
je veux bien le croire voilà ça c'est il
ya une stratégie une feuille de ses
global de la stratégie des traces et
isolée en partie en raison de tests au
service d'un traçage qui a pas et
efficace dont il faudrait c'est de
comprendre pourquoi je n'ai pas toutes
les raisons il ya des clairement des
problèmes il ya le fiasco de
d'applications stop qu'ovide qui va être
abandonnée on sait pas exactement
pourquoi exactement encore le tout senti
qu vie de vos soirées dit macro hier ou
aujourd'hui lille 0 1 face à moi je sais
pas vous rendre compte et je sais
toujours pas si si ce sera finalement
une application qui va être utilisé pour
pour tester auto matin pour trouver
automatiquement dès qu'un contact ou non
qu'on l'a laissé entendre hier aux
différents a dit que en changer
complètement de de stratégie aujourd'hui
donc je sais pas très bien ce qu'il ya
derrière
mais cet appui dans sap co vide en a
quand même on a quand même pas beaucoup
fait la promotion au mans
au début de l'été on ça repartait ou
s'ils ont été utiles il voit là et dire
aux gens ben voilà sous les panneaux
lumineux tout le temps à lui mais là
quand vous êtes dans les transports à
lui mais là quand vous êtes au
restaurant et lui a promis quand vous
sortez dans un bar si vous voulez pas
aller lui mais tout le temps prenez ayez
le bon réflexe
c'est pas que rêver aucune campagne à ce
sujet la seule campagne qui a eu c'était
si vous voyez votre grand-mère cet été
gardez vos distances bon ben c'est fin
c'est cette campagne et s'était justifié
mais il n'y a pas eu d'autres choses
quoi donc l'outil était là et on a fait
semblant qu'il n'existait pas on a enfin
comme on avait voilà acté le fait que
c'était un échec alors que je pense
qu'il y avait des ses pattes fait
brandir des menaces plus précocément
disant voilà mais je vois le couvre-feu
a été adopté un peu en catimini on a
appris deux jours avant comment comment
voulez-vous brandir la menace d'un
couvre-feu début août si vous même vous
savez pas quoi parlait pas je comptais
lille une espèce de volonté de croire
que l'épidémie repartait pas alors que
tous les indicateurs repartait donc à
une faillite collective portant sur des
piques france disait bien que l'épidémie
repartait au leader en âme et conscience
il ne disait l'information n'est pas
passée on voulait pas l'entendre
je ne sais pas iliad est un travail d un
avis très compliqué on peut comprendre
pourquoi le message ne passe pas mais de
toute évidence
voilà le message
connaissant les passants une dernière
question tristan
un syndicaliste qui nous dit sur
lefigaro.fr les tests les masques etc ne
servent finalement qu'à camoufler le
manque de volonté sur le système de
santé au vu l'hiver en lui même a fait
référence aux au numerus clausus dans sa
dans sa prise de parole qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce commentaire je je je
on peut débattre longtemps de
l'évolution du système de santé ces dix
dernières années et de la baule les
hôpitaux etc
les semaines d'alarmé ont été tirés
depuis très longtemps
voilà ça pas été pris en compte il ya
des défis multiples à ce niveau là le
fait est que c'est pas en six mois qu'on
aurait pu renverser la tendance donc je
pense qu'il ya un moment dans l'urgence
il faut je peux dire qu'il faut
abandonner la polémique mais ces gens là
on les a par ailleurs les apps pour les
a peu entendu j'ai entendu si on est un
peu attendu cet été mais ce qu'il ya un
temps pour tout voilà il attend dans
l'urgence il faut quand même que les
personnes soignants et des masques il
faut qu'on essaie de faire des tests
il faut qu'on ait des brigades de
traçage préoccupe c'est un mauvais
procès de dire que mettre tout ça en
place
cachée est fait pour cacher la faillite
du système de santé
non c'est juste que c'est aussi un
important système de santé et prouvent
des difficultés depuis longtemps ce
n'est pas en six mois qu'on allait
régler et c'est pas en n'ayant pas de
masque pas de tester pas de traçage qu
on aurait eu plus de vie dorée alors
c'est un peu un à mon sens un sens c'est
un faux débat
à l'heure actuelle je pense que le vrai
enjeu c'est dur c'est de limiter
drastiquement voilà le losc à shanghai
où c'est l'allemagne qui a juste à
comprendre souvent en exemple qui est un
plus
cinq fois plus de de l'île de ré à que
nous parle par habitant met en place des
mesures similaires à celles que prend la
france avant nous dansons épidémie dire
avant même d'être niveau de saturation
de rien qu'on atteint ils prennent déjà
des mesures de la même
la même intensité donc voilà c'est pas
le c'est pas une finalité en soi le
problème est ailleurs les allemands
avant bien avant d'être submergé se
disent déjà que dans trois mois ils vont
s'immerger que c'est pas possible et
prenne des mesures
nous on n'attend que d'être au bord du
gouffre pour pour donner un violent coup
de barre et et on a vu
on a vu en mars n'était pas la bonne
solution et on est encore là on peut
répéter la même chose c'est sais comment
c'est quand même triste une toute toute
dernière question qui nous vient de
twitch de la part de napolitain est ce
que l'appli stop coville qui va devenir
donc tous antico vide à partir de jeudi
prochain jeudi 22 octobre est ce qu'elle
sera obligatoire tout simplement j'ai
j'irai je n'ai pas j'ai pas l'impression
sahel en tout cas pour l'instant rien de
l'espoir c'est ça la seule chose qui
pourrait laisser penser qu'elle le soit
dans certains lieux
c'est l'idée c'est l'idée qu'elle soit
rendue obligatoire pour aller au
restaurant par exemple
mais après je maîtrise mal les le côté
discriminatoire que ça pourrait avoir ce
quelqu'un a pas de smartphone par
exemple aujourd'hui est un smartphone on
est interdit de restaurants je sais pas
dans quelle mesure ça pourrait être mise
en oeuvre
donc voilà ma connaissance non le leader
jamais été de rendre ce jour 2
d'application obligatoire je vois mal
comment ça pourrait le devenir c'est
quand même très très discriminatoire en
france
merci beaucoup triste enlevé chef
adjoint du service science médecine du
figaro d'avoir pris ce temps pour
débriefer avec nous à cette conférence
de presse de jean castex et de plusieurs
ministres merci à toutes et à tous de
l'avoir suivi sur youtube sur twitch sur
lefigaro.fr joueurs récapitule
rapidement les annonces principal couvre
feu donc ça s'est confirmé évidemment
qui entre en vigueur dans la nuit de
vendredi à samedi ce sera 21h
6 heures accurso qui commence à minuit
dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi
l'ile-de-france rouen lille lyon
grenoble saint-etienne aix marseille
montpellier toulouse à 21h tous les
lieux recevant du public devront être
fermés les déplacements qui seront
autorisées bien ce sera pour aller par
exemple à l'hôpital acheter des
médicaments
si on commence ou si on termine bien sa
vacation professionnel il faudra
télécharger soit sur le téléphone soit
imprimé soir copié sur papier une
attestation 1 comme au printemps qui va
être disponible dans les heures qui
viennent normalement sur le site du
gouvernement
et puis sur le site du ministère de
l'intérieur j'ai vu une question aussi
de bobby sur lefigaro.fr
concernant les déplacements ainsi on a
un train ou un avion qui part ou qui
arrivent après 21h et bien là on n'y
aura pas de pas de difficulté un je
pense qu'il faudra remplir une
attestation là aussi mais en tout cas
pas de difficultés si votre train ou
votre avion arrive ou par après 21h
c'est en tout cas ce qu'a dit jean
castex pas de problème non plus bas pour
sortir son animal de compagnie
imprécisions c'est assez utile également
mesure qui s'applique pour quatre
semaines un mois six semaines début
décembre
c'est l'objectif fixé par le président
et le gouvernement
après passage de 7 de ce couvre-feu
devant le parlement au passage aussi de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire qui sera
rétablie à partir de samedi les fêtes de
mariage les soirées étudiantes interdite
et puis la règle du un siège sur deux
qui va s'appliquer dans tous les lieux
où l'on doit justement être assis comme
les cinémas ou encore les stades
merci à toutes et à tous d'avoir suivi
cette conférence de presse et puis ce
débriefing merci à neurones à
syndicaliste a beau but justement
d'avoir été avec nous à gérard également
sur la home merci à toutes et à tous
tarek ou encore
jocelyne d'avoir été avec nous sur
youtube et puis merci aléas à rio web à
10 10 cartman d'avoir été avec nous sur
twitter
l'actualité est à retrouver sur figaro
live et sur lefigaro.fr très bonne après
midi